egal wer ist denn wenn man seine augen
einzeln bewegen könnte wie so ein
richtiger fried ich hatte schon so auf
den film gesehen und mich immer gefragt
wie machen wie das haben die gegen
welche muskeln die ich nicht habe und
kann ich das deswegen gar nicht lernen
nein das kann jeder lernen und zwar
vielleicht alles gedacht erschreckend
einfach wirklich gruselig recht wenn ihr
also auch eure freunde beeindrucken
möchten hält dann sorgen bereiten möchte
dann bleibt dran
ich habe es mir diese woche wieder als
ziel gesetzt etwas verrücktes zu lernen
und euch dabei mitzunehmen wenn du sowas
interessiert dann lass mir doch ein abo
darum nichts mehr zu verpassen
nachdem ich die idee hatte zu lernen wie
man seine augen unabhängig von einander
bewegt habe ich direkt angefangen zu
recherchieren denn um zu wissen wie man
ein einzelnes auge bewegt muss man
verstehen wie das menschliche auge
eigentlich funktioniert augen haben
sechs muskeln und ihr müsst nicht wissen
wie deren viel zu komplizierte namen
heißen merkt euch einfach dass es
muskeln gibt und das auge nach links
rechts oben unten gegen den
uhrzeigersinn und mit dem uhrzeigersinn
zu drehen jaja augen können sich auch
darum drehen und man kann es auch
kontrollieren lernen ich bin selber mega
gruselig vielleicht kommt ja noch mal
video dazu für unsere vorhaben müssen
wir die muskeln trainieren die unsere
augen von links nach rechts drehen und
um diese muskeln best wirklich aufbauen
zu können findet dieses protein pulver
war wie ihr alle wisst haben menschen
genauso wie die meisten anderen tiere
zwei augen mit der das sind 42 augen um
dreidimensional sehen zu können und um
dadurch abschätzen zu können wie weit
die dinge dann entfernt sind die man so
sieht das rechte auge sieht also fast
das gleiche wie das linke auge nur eben
leicht versetzt und durch das überlagern
der beiden bilder vermittelt uns eben
unser gehirn die illusion der dritten
dimension an sich die kennen das
wahrscheinlich vom kino wo man eine
spezielle brille drauf hat die eben
spezielle filter drin hat mit der man
eben mit dem rechten auge in minimal
anderes bild sieht also mit dem linken
auge und dadurch dreidimensional sehen
kann und jetzt kommen wir zu unserem
erstaunlich leichten aber unfassbar
kleinen trick wenn man so will haben
unsere augen zwei verschiedene arten
dinge zu fokussieren einmal das scharf
stellen die man es von einer kamera
kennt bei der das einfallende licht
richtig gebündelt beziehungsweise scharf
gestellt wird für unseren trick aber
viel wichtiger ist die zweite art dinge
zu fokussieren bei der die augen
voneinander oder zueinander gedreht
werden um die beiden einzelbilder der
augen richtig zu überlagern einfach das
experiment haltet euren finger für euren
bildschirm und jetzt guckt auf mich
jetzt gut auf eure finger jetzt gut auf
mich
auf mich wir sind dabei entweder mich
oder euren finger doppelt und das ist
einfach nur der versuch eures gehirn ist
diese beiden einzelnen bilder
zusammenzufügen um dadurch ein
dreidimensionales erlebnis zu kreieren
aber natürlich kann nur immer ein objekt
berechtigt überlappt werden und alles
davor oder dahinter zieht sie dann
einfach zweimal und ich denke dass das
bei diesem experiment ziemlich
offensichtlich wird die erste arzt des
fokussieren so wie es eben auch bei der
kamera ist mit dem scharf oder unscharf
werde ich im folgenden schärfe focus
nennen und die zweite arzt fokussieren
bei dem die augen aufeinander
zugerichtet werden um dinge 3d sehen zu
können werde ich jetzt 3d focus nennen
das sind unfassbar unwissenschaftliche
und dumme begriffe also merkt ihr euch
auf jeden fall nicht und auf jeden fall
erzählt den leuten nicht dass ihr den
unsinn von mir habt und genau dieses 3d
fokussieren kann man jetzt nicht nur
automatisch indem man einfach auf dinge
guckt und das auge das schon regelt
sondern man kann auch wirklich lernen
das zu kontrollieren und dadurch auf den
punkt fokussieren den es eigentlich gar
nicht gibt genauso funktioniert übrigens
das normale schielen bei dem man einfach
auf den punkt hier zwischen seinen augen
guckt und dadurch dann kurz deine augen
zusammen bewegt weil stellt euch vor ihr
habt jetzt den finger und dann guckt ihr
hier hin da müssen ja die augen so
gucken damit den finger sehen und
deswegen werden die hier so gedreht und
dieses drehen können wir für unseren
trick missbrauchen ich habe das irgendwo
gelesen und es ist echt genial
warum weiß dass noch nicht jeder weil
weil es ist wirklich leute es ist
wirklich es ist wirklich genial der
trick besteht einfach darin ein objekt
anzugucken langsam den 3d fokus zu
verschieben bis das doppelt sieht und
dann statt jetzt wie üblich durch diese
beiden einzelbilder hindurch zu gucken
wie es gerade in diesem beispiel clip
seht müsst ihr euch auf eines der beiden
bilder festlegen den 3d fokus hin und
her verschieben und immer mit den augen
auf dem festgelegten ich bleiben es ist
echt geil
leichter gesagt als getan ich gebe euch
mal ein paar coole übungen mit denen ihr
das leicht und spielerisch trainieren
könnte übung nummer eins haltet ein
stift oder einen finger vor euer gesicht
und guckt ihn an
dann guckt durch den fingern hindurch
bisher ein doppelt seht dann guckt
wieder auf den fingern merkte er wie
sich die beiden finger genau symmetrisch
zur seite verschieben und ihr genau
durch die mitte hindurch guckt jetzt
guckt wieder durch euren finger hindurch
aber diesmal entscheidet euch für einen
der beiden finger und verfolgt den
einfach mit euren augen und zack schon
bewegt der ein auge während das auge mit
dem ihr den finger verfolgt still bleibt
macht das ein paar mal in versucht dabei
die beiden einzelbilder immer langsamer
und kontrollierter voneinander weg zu
bringen bis ihr wirklich den abstand
komplett mit euren verstand
kontrollieren könnte bei dieser zweiten
übung übt er kontrolliert den 3d
fokuspunkt von wald weg an euch nahe
heran zu bringen halte jetzt wieder
einen finger vor euch und guckt ihn an
dann merkt euren kopf nach hinten bis
ihr eure nase vor dem finger sieht und
fokussiert dann auf eure nase wodurch
ihr wieder euren finger doppelt sieht
diesmal sind wir den finger nicht
doppelt weil er einen punkt dahinter
fokussiert sondern weil er einen punkt
davor fokussiert jetzt guckt immer
wieder zwischen eurem finger und eurer
nase hin und her und versucht den
fokuspunkt zwischen eurem finger und
eurer nase langsamer und kontrollierter
hin und her zu verschieben bis er ihn
letztendlich wieder komplett mit euren
verstand kontrollieren könnte jetzt
macht euren kopf wieder gerade guckt auf
den finger und zieht den 3d fokus so
langsam zurück genau wie vorher mit der
nase nur dass er diesmal nicht auf die
nase fokussiert sondern auf einen
virtuellen punkt darüber der eben genau
vor euch liegt nachdem ihr diese übungen
ein paar mal gemacht habt uns das gefühl
hat der könnte in 3 d focus richtig
richtig gut kontrollieren können wir
jetzt damit was echt nicht verrücktes
machen und wirklich wenn ich verrückt
man dann meine verrückt und zwar gibt es
im internet 3d videos die man ohne
brille gucken kann die wirklich richtig
verrückt sind einfach indem man quasi
seinen fokus verändert und zum beispiel
gibt dieses komplett geisteskranke
minecraft video was aber für den anfang
ein bisschen zu schwer ist deswegen
probiert mal dieses leichtere beispiel
alles was abwärts com funktioniert
übrigens viel viel besser am handy als
auf dem pc deswegen kann ich empfehlen
wenn ihr die möglichkeit habt wechselt
jetzt auf ihr handy
jetzt perfekt was er jetzt machen müsst
ist den fokus so weit zurück zu euch zu
ziehen
bis sich die beiden schwarzen punkte
unten im video überlappen wenn ihr
schwierigkeiten dabei habt habe ich noch
einen ultra guten trick für euch nehmt
euren finger und halte den unten mittig
an euren bildschirm dann guckt auf den
finger und zieht den finger langsam zu
euch bis sich die beiden schwarzen
punkte im hintergrund genau überlappen
wenn die beiden punkte schräg versetzt
sind dann dreht euren bildschirm oder
euren kopf ein wenig biss ihr gerade
sein wenn sich die beiden punkte
überlassen habt ihr den richtigen 3d
focus gefunden
jetzt guckt nicht mehr hören finger an
sondern den punkt direkt aktuell ist
wahrscheinlich immer noch alles unscharf
aber wenn ihr den 3 d focus lange genug
halten könnt langsam nach oben in die
mitte des bildes guckt ohne den drei den
fokus zu verlieren und wenn nötig etwas
in die 3
lead hinein fühlt stellen eure augen das
mittige bild scharf und ihr könnt das
video gestochen scharf in 3d sehen ohne
brille die die farben komisch verzerrt
so wie im kino ein weiteres beispiel ist
zum beispiel diese 3d hawk-eye branchen
was auch immer das ist aber zusammen mit
diesem geilen bild dem 3d unter heftigen
musik bringt es euch wirklich einem
komplett ob ihr dasein wollte an diesem
ort weiß ich auch nicht aber probiert
mal aus und als ich das vor hin zum
ersten mal hingekriegt hat war es
wirklich ein extrem heftiges gefühl für
mich und wie gesagt dieses kann ich euch
sehr zu empfehlen weil das ich euch auch
empfehlen kann ist dieses video mit
einigen reallife beispielen link zu
allen ist natürlich in der video
beschreibung und das absolut wichtigste
ist dass hier dieser minecraft zug der
wirklich komplett also die leute sowas
hat man noch nicht gesehen wird das ist
echt der reinste drogentrip es ist
wirklich geil es ist das ist es ist
wirklich richtig geil kleine warnung
macht das ganze nicht zu lang weil wenn
ihr eure augen so krass ver kreuzt dann
kann es schon mal sein dass ein bisschen
kopfschmerzen kriegt aber nichts
langfristiges nach ein paar minuten
stunden ist es auf jeden fall wieder weg
und kleiner tipp wenn ihr sowas gemacht
habt und immer so extrem nah fokussiert
hat weil er guckt ja auf euren
bildschirm allerdings überkreuzen sich
eure augen ja so als würdet ihr quasi
ich hierhin fokussieren und dadurch
fokussierte quasi immer einen ziemlich
ziemlich nahe punkt an mit euren augen
uns deswegen kann es schon mal wirklich
entspannend sein danach für ein paar
minuten in die entfernung zu gucken
wirklich weit weg so weit wie es eben
geht hier in köln kann die ungefähr fünf
meter weit gucken dann ist schon raus da
das nur so als kleine
sicherheitsmaßnahme wirklich gefährlich
ist es aber nicht diese art von videos
nennt sich auto stehe hier gramm ihr
findet es auch unter dem namen cross
video und damit kredite es in 3 d focus
nach hinten zu euch zu bringen in 3 d
focus nach vorne beziehungsweise weg von
euch zu schieben könnte mit etwas üben
was sich hinten friedy beziehungsweise
versteckt das 3d nennt das sind bilder
die auf dem ersten blick aussehen als
wäre euer bildschirm kaputt aber auf dem
zweiten blick
nee da sieht es immer noch komisch aus
aber wenn ihr das display relativ nah an
eure augen heranbringt und den 3d fokus
etwas hinter das display schieben bis er
das bild doppelt seht könnt ihr mit
etwas herumprobieren richtig kohle 3d
bilder sehen bei diesem bild zum
beispiel sieht man einen schmetterling
wenn ihr das auch ausprobieren möchtet
dann macht jetzt stoppt weil jetzt kommt
das nächste mit dem hier sieht man eine
löwin
bei dem hier ein küsschen und bei dem
hier schreibt die kommentare was ihr da
seht das ist nämlich nachdem wir jetzt
eine menge spaß hatten unsere augen zu
trainieren und in komische welten
einzutauchen wird es jetzt ernst wir
probieren einen auge einzeln zu bewegen
ohne irgendwelche hilfsmittel ohne
irgendwelche stifte oder finger sucht
dafür einen markanten punkte oder
gegenstand in eure umgebung und guckt
ihn an und dann zieht den 3 d focus
zurück in richtung eure augen wie in
unsere übung vorher müsst ihr aber jetzt
dafür sorgen dass sich die beiden bilder
nicht symmetrisch nach links und rechts
auseinander schieben wie in diesem
beispiel clip sondern euch auf eines der
beiden einzelbilder konzentrieren und
das anvisieren während sich die beiden
bilder weg schieben damit quasi das bild
nicht hier so symmetrisch nach außen
geschoben wird sondern eine statisch ist
und dass andere sich nur weg bewegt so
wie ihr es gerade in diesem beispiel
sieht wenn euch das gelingt habt ihr ist
auch schon geschafft dann habt ihr
wirklich das zertifikat eure freunde zu
beeindrucken oder eure eltern zu
beunruhigen aber bitte sagt den einfach
nicht dass er den mist von mir gelernt
habt danke das ist das zweite video in
dem ich etwas lernen und euch auf man
den lehrern reise mitnehmen wir bei dem
video war so ein bisschen anders ich
hab's nicht genau dokumentiert wie es
gelernt hat das werden wir nicht
spannend zu sehen wie die stundenlange
vor der kamera sind meine augen die
ganze zeit hin und her dass nee das ist
deswegen jetzt noch wie immer am ende
der videos werbung in eigener sache wenn
ihr schneiden lernen möchte dann kann
ich euch mal schnittkurs empfehlen da
lernt ihr richtig gut schneiden
innerhalb von kürzester zeit link dazu
ist in der video beschreibung und ich
arbeite aktuell immer noch mit meinem
team an einem richtig kassen minecraft
server in dem es ein richtiges
klassensystem eigene 3d alten scholes
und noch viel viel mehr richtig cooles
zeug wenn ihr daran interesse hat ist
dafür der diskont link in der video
beschreibung und wenn ihr mich auf
dieser reise begleiten möchte dann
abonniert diesen kanal dann sehen wir
zum nächsten mal wieder macht's gut
jo
[Musik]